[MUSIC]
[APPLAUSE]
>> Hi, Doug.
>> Hi, Tracy.
>> Thank you so much for coming today.
>> Thanks for having me.
This is wonderful.
>> We're looking forward to
the conversation.
>> Happy to be here.
This is really nice.
Thank you all for being here.
I appreciate it.
>> I was hoping we could start
when you were in our shoes,
when you were just starting
out on your career,
your first job out of business school
was as an analyst at American Airlines.
>> Correct.
>> You moved around between a couple of
different airline companies after that but
never left the industry.
What drew you to that first job at
American, and to the airline industry?
>> Yeah, you're going to test my memory.
It's a long time ago.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But no, a lot of people in our industry
that you will find just grew up
with jet fuel in their veins.
Sit and watch airplanes take off when
they were 12 years old, at the airport.
I didn't do any of that stuff.
I was not a huge commercial aviation
enthusiast or anything like it.
I was looking for a job.
I'd gone straight through from
undergrad to graduate school.
My concentration was in finance.
I wanted to go somewhere
where finance was important.
So I looked toward heavily
capitalized industries.
And airlines popped up.
So, as in a number of others, it wasn't so
much airlines, and I was fortunate enough
that, at the time, American Airlines
was trying to build a hub in Nashville,
Tennessee, where I was getting my MBA,
so they came to campus.
I interviewed, and
they invited me back to Dallas.
I liked the people there.
It really was as simple as that.
I knew I wanted to go somewhere where what
I was reasonably proficient at mattered.
>> Yeah.
>> So
that was as targeted as I did though, and
then it was just having done it,
I loved it.
It's a fantastic business,
it's really dynamic.
So that's kind of why I stayed in,
it I think.
But it wasn't anything
more scientific than that.
>> It makes sense.
But you did stay in the industry.
And many of us,
many of our generation are job hoppers.
A lot of us, our next jobs, we won't be
there in more than a couple of years.
What's your advice as someone who
stayed in the same industry for so
long to people who are thinking
about jumping between companies and
industries over the course
of their careers?
>> Again, see, all I know is what I did,
so it's hard to suggest that that's
the only way to do it, because it's not.
But what happened with me, again,
is I got into this business.
I found I really enjoyed it.
What I like about the airline business
is that all the disciplines
are really important.
I said I wanted to go somewhere finance
matter, but finance does matter, but
it's a consumer product so
marketing's incredibly important.
There's no more complex
operation in the world so
logistics is incredibly
important in value.
The maintenance function is
really a manufacturing function.
So every discipline's really important.
And how you make all those things
come together is really important.
So what I liked about it is the ability
to gravitate to different Items,
areas over time.
But so much staying in the industry,
I don't know.
I know at time,
I contemplated doing other things.
It wasn't that I think no, I need to
stay in this business for any reason.
It's just the opportunities that came
around continued to be in the same
business.
Now I don't think I could do anything
else, this is all I've done, but
I don't know.
I will say that it's certainly
nice when we bring in people
from the outside because you
bring in a fresh perspective.
And people in our business tend to have
hold on to some views of the past that
maybe we don't want to hold on to anymore.
So there's always some value in
bringing people in from the outside,
but there's also a tremendous amount
of value of having people who have
been in the business and know it and
have seen the cycles and understand.
So I think either way,
we need some of each.
But there certainly is,
if we find someone who is just in for
a couple years and out,
it's not particularly helpful to us.
Because it takes longer than that to
really figure out what's going on.
>> When you first arrived
at this company that has so
many different disciplines
that are important.
>> You hadn't been watching the planes
take off when you were a kid, and
there's a lot of value from
the industry expertise.
Just starting out, how did you make a name
for yourself in a company like that?
>> Yeah, you show up and do your job.
And try and
make sure that you're being responsive
to what the organization's looking for.
Again, I wasn't incredibly
hard-driving cutthroat,
I'm going to make sure that I get
this job before someone else does.
But I certainly cared about what I did,
I took it seriously.
And I worked really hard,
I took pride in the work that I did and
people noticed that.
And so it wasn't so much that I was
going to figure out how I got to this job
by this time but rather I showed up and
did the job that I was asked to do.
I think I did it pretty well and
people recognized that and
they want you to do more things.
And of course then what really matters is
as you start moving up in an organization,
the skills that might have been
really helpful as an analyst,
are not particularly the ones that
are as important as a manager.
So you gotta figure out how to adapt and
do those things but anyway,
I tried to do what I was asked to do.
I took it really seriously.
I worked pretty hard,
because it mattered to me.
But if you do that people will find you.
>> Yeah, were there any key people or
key events that helped you,
especially when you were moving
up into new positions where
maybe you didn't have the skills yet?
>> Yeah, well, what I remember
from back then where my career
really started to progress little
faster is when I was promoted.
I was a pretty good analyst, but there
were definitely better analysts than me.
Smarter, good at Lotus 123, or
whatever the hell we used back then.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> Yeah, so
anyway, they could build
a spreadsheet faster.
I was pretty good but
definitely not the best.
Where my career started progressing
is when I was promoted to
managing a small group of people.
And I've always liked working in teams.
Played team sports growing up.
I was comfortable in that environment,
and I quickly realized that if I can just
get these five people who are smarter
than me to work together,
we can do a lot more than
the six of us can independently.
And I did find that I think
I did that role better
than certainly my peers at the time.
Our team was able to produce more.
I tried to make sure they all got credits,
so then people wanted to be on my team,
and as a result, that's when things
started taking off for me a little more.
>> Interesting, a lot of these dynamics
are the dynamics of a more traditional,
complex company that's been around for
a while and has its hierarchies.
A lot of us are looking at jobs in
Silicon Valley, where we move fast and
break things, which isn't necessarily
how I would describe American Airlines.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So give us the other perspective.
What can we learn at this point in our
careers from an established company that
we couldn't learn at a start up?
>> Yeah, well that's a hard question for
me to answer you.
Again, back when I came out, there wasn't
an internet and there weren't people,
the best and
brightest didn't go work at start ups.
They went and worked at established firms.
So it's what I knew.
But look, the basic principles.
I'm certain, are the same.
That is leadership skills.
Getting people to work as a unit.
Communicating with people in a way that
they understand what the mission of
the organization is.
In a way that they feel
motivated to produce.
That's how you're successful
in a large organization.
I can't imagine that's not how you're
successful in a smaller organization.
And look, the large organization
stuff may sound old and stodgy.
I think the reason our team
has done as well as we have,
given the cards we were handed anyway,
is because
I think we think much more like a startup,
that startup mentality.
We took risk others wouldn't take.
We didn't things people
thought were crazy.
And there's so
much value to be created if you're willing
to do that in large organizations.
Because the organization doesn't,
it will reward behavior,
but it doesn't encourage the behavior.
If, anyway, any of you,
if asked look, this is,
I'll give you a roll a dice,
if it comes up six,
I'll give you a $50, but
it comes didn't come as six.
You gotta pay me five.
Well, I gotta well, of course.
You give me ten to one odds in
something that's one in six.
If you mention that to your boss in
a large organization, I got this idea,
the boss will say wait a second,
you're telling me five out of six times.
It's not going to work.
I'm going to look bad
five out of six times.
We're not doing that.
So, those of us who are willing to say,
what are you talking about?
I don't care.
It's a great bet, we're going to do that.
Do extremely well because the risk
reward relationship works of course
like it does everywhere else.
And you're in an environment
where risk is less encouraged.
So the reward is
much higher than it would be if everyone
was taking the same level of risk.
Or had the same attitude.
So look,
again I only know what I've been through.
But I don't feel like it's been boring and
stodgy.
It's been incredibly dynamic and exciting.
And the fun part is taking these risks and
seeing, and when other's don't.
And having some things that others
would look at and think of God,
that didn't work for you,
which we say it's exactly the way.
I would never,
I would do the exact same thing.
>> Yeah.
>> Because it was the right decision.
Just because it came up too,
doesn't mean it was the wrong
decision to take that back.
It was the right decision.
So, and
as long as you keep doing those things,
particularly in an organization where
you're not competing with a lot of people
doing the same thing,
you can do really well.
>> And
is this perspective you've developed about
being willing to take the risk, has this
developed and changed over your career?
>> I don't think so.
>> All right.
>> Yeah, I don't know.
I used to like going to Vegas
a lot when I was younger.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So, and, look, I've,
I'm a big proponent of risk taking,
and always have been.
So, and like I say,
it's helped me a lot, and
things like just in
the introduction of my career.
When I left,
this is inside airline stuff, so sorry.
But you know, back when I left American
Airlines in, whatever that was, 1991.
American Airlines,
that was the place to be.
We hired 40 amazing year.
We were the best and the brightest.
No one went to work for Northwest
Airlines, for God sakes, from American,
but I did.
>> Yeah.
>> Because I could do a lot more at
Northwest than I could at American.
So anyway,
I would encourage people to go take risks.
That's what I've been doing for
a long time.
>> Good.
Since the Vegas days.
>> Exactly.
>> But
combined with your risk taking style.
There's also a lot out there who say
you have a leadership style that's
very humble.
Very confident but very humble.
And the airline industry has a lot
of folks with some pretty big egos.
>> They've got confidence.
>> Yes,
yes everyone's got the confidence, but
the humility I think is
the distinctive feature.
What are the trade offs between the two
different styles when you're running such
a complex organization?
So many different people to communicate
with as you expressed before?
>> Okay, well thanks for
the characterization.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I appreciate that.
I hope it's true.
What I know is that, this is huge
team sport and there's no individual that
makes a difference and the way it makes
a difference is if you get the whole team
pulling together and working together.
So I'm stunned sometimes to see how
some individuals try and position
themselves because I can't imagine what
it's like to work for that person.
When you're he one doing all the work and
they're taking all the credit.
>> Yeah.
>> So I try not to do that.
It's hard by the way because
people want to do that.
Media only wants to talk to me and
everyone
wants to try and simplify it into you made
this decision, you made this decision.
And I didn't make those decisions.
Somebody else made those decisions.
I was just, I said okay.
So at any rate, I don't think it's
a conscious attempt to try and
be different than anybody.
It's just who we are.
And what we've learned long ago is that
if we all work together as a team and
stick together as a team,
we can do really great things.
But if any one of us tries to make it
about us, then it starts to fall apart.
So that's worked for us.
Other ways work for other people.
That's just what works for us.
>> Yeah.
Building on that, the airline industry
is one that invokes a lot of negative
sentiment among customers sometimes.
>> Really?
>> The Wall Street Journal,
I've heard it mentioned.
The Wall Street Journal recently published
a report showing that American Airlines
was ranked last in sort of overall
ranking of US airlines for 2015.
>> I didn't read that one.
>> [LAUGH] I'll send it to you.
>> Sure it's wrong.
>> Probably.
Probably.
Just a slip up.
>> Okay.
>> Maybe I was looking at it upside down.
But.
>> [LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH] [APPLAUSE] [COUGH]
Well what I want to know is in a team
sport and you're the team captain and
there's result like this,
how do you lead the team?
>> Well you understand the results and
make sure, look I did read the article and
you didn't read it upside down.
But look,
we are in the middle of integration
during the time that was measured.
So things like what they
measured are important.
But some of the things they
measured are really hard to do,
when you are running two separate airline,
like baggage connections.
>> Yeah.
>> When we've got people connecting from
US Airways to American Airlines,
it's harder.
All that, we are well aware of that.
That's the problem with integration
we are that stuffs fixed.
We won't be last next year.
American Airlines is one airline now.
And first and
foremost that's the answer, but
to your broader,
that specific set of circumstances but
I'm not about to suggest
we do everything great,
it's a great business and
people shouldn't complain.
It's a difficult function to
transport people through bad
weather like we're about
to have in the East coast.
And people fail out for the product and
there's, if we do everything perfectly,
if we do or just perfectly well then
The air press perfectly maintained,
everyone shows up on time, everyone
does their job exactly as they should.
The best we're going to do,
in terms of on time performance,
over the course of a year anyway,
is probably around 85%.
85% of the time you should
expect at the very,
very best run airline that you're going to
arrive within, by the way the definition
of on time is within 14 minutes of your
scheduled arrival time, which is nice too.
>> [LAUGH]
>> That's our government, but
none the less,
what other business has 15% failure rates?
>> Yeah.
>> And for a product, but
that's entirely due to weather.
In the example I just gave,
there's no maintenance, cancellations.
50% of our flights get
delayed because of weather.
So we have this challenge of
a product that is a means to an end.
Most people don't buy airline tickets
to fly around in an airplane,
they're trying to get somewhere else.
And is also because of how complicated
it is, and how capital intensive it is.
It's reasonably expensive, so they expect
it to work as a means to an end, and
when it doesn't, they get upset.
Now our challenge is to make sure
that we manage that as well, and
we're getting much better at this.
When things do go wrong, make sure that we
were able to respond much more quickly and
get people where they need to go.
because people do understand weather.
But they still want to get
where they were trying to go.
Anyway, I've already forget what the
question was, Gracie, but we work really
hard in a difficult job to do it
really well and to focus on customers.
We have a phenomenal team of people.
We got over 100,000 employees who are just
out there doing a great job everyday,
it's a really noble thing they do.
They get beat up sometimes because they're
the ones standing there when the plane
can't go, but the reality is,
those people,
they make commerce run, business couldn't
operate without the airline industry.
They get people to go see other people,
they get people to go see the world.
And it all happens because of the work
they do and we're really proud of it.
But we know we have to get
better at reaccommodating
people when things go wrong.
>> Yeah.
And related to things beyond your control,
ten days
after you became CEO of US Airways
>> You woke up to the news that
two planes had crashed into
the World Trade Center.
What went through your head at that
moment and what did you do that morning?
>> Yeah, I was in Phoenix at the time,
working for America West Airlines.
Yeah, I was the CEO for ten days.
It was a nice ten days.
>> And then-
>> [LAUGH]
>> It's all relative.
>> So look, the immediate concern of
course was for the safety of our team, so
quickly after learning about
the flights at the World Trade Center.
My phone rang and
it was the FAA was grounding
the entire commercial airline fleet.
And so we were putting airplanes down.
So the best message I got was hearing that
everyone of our airplanes was safe and
they were on the ground, so.
But anyway,
it quickly turns into the next three days,
trying to shut down airspace and
those things.
But not much longer, once you get
past the immediate safety concerns.
And by the way, extreme empathy for
those who didn't have their employees
safe at American and United.
But shortly thereafter, we moved into,
what are we going to do about the longterm
viability of this business and this, and
particularly the company that I was
running which was America West Airlines?
We had a range to financing
with some suppliers of ours,
Airbus and GE, to help get us through
what was already a tough time.
It was arranged but
we have not fully executed.
So that of course, fell through.
We found ourselves in a position where we
absolutely in that environment did not
have enough cash to make
it through the winter.
We were going to go, and in that
environment, since there was no way,
even through a bankruptcy filing
to expect things like dip loans
that would allow you to survive,
we were going to shut the company down.
We were going to liquidate without
some sort of capital infusion.
So and the only possible way to get
a capital infusion in that environment was
the US Government.
They established this
Government Loan Guarantee Program so
I went from,
when I took the job in September of 2001.
The one thing I remember telling the board
is look, I can do all this stuff.
I've done operations, I've done the
marquee side, I've done the finance side.
The only thing I really haven't done
is government affairs, but that's okay,
because we're this little
airline in Phoenix and
we never had to do anything
with Washington, really.
It's more the bigger
airlines mess with that.
Well, I was found myself living
in Washington DC, lobbying for
a government loan for
the next three months.
>> Crash course.
>> Yeah.
>> How did you communicate?
So you had a lot of communications with
the government the month that followed.
How did you think about the various
communications to the public,
to customers, employees, shareholders.
>> Yeah, we tried to make them
think everything was okay.
Even though we weren't quite sure it was,
we were honest.
Let everybody know that we were
going to get this done even though we
weren't certain we were.
So the communication was important, but
the real important part was trying
to get through the loan process.
It's by the way,
I'm going to embarrass somebody.
Is Marlena Sloick in here?
Hi.
Her father John Sloick was our
investment banker through all of this.
He lived through this with me, so anyway.
>> Good to see you.
Thanks for coming.
>> Nice to see you.
Thanks.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Tell your dad hi.
>> So anyway, he and
I went through a lot together.
But I want to give you one quick
story which I think can help
pull this together and
also this career stuff.
because seeing Marlena
reminded me of this.
We went through this process and
we were told by the government, no.
We were told.
Marlena's father and I sat there and
had the Department of the Treasury
send us a fax at Citi's government
affairs office Friday at 5 PM,
so they could then leave,
that said we've reviewed your file,
and need to tell you that we cannot
approve your application at this time.
Which is no.
And it's the worst day of my life.
We were going to liquidate, and I didn't
know what we were going to do about it.
And again, from this time now, so it's
now, I'm the CEO of this airline, I've
been CEO, this is now October, November,
so I've been seeing them for two months.
>> Very experienced.
>> Yeah, exactly.
So I just can't help but think,
this didn't turn out right.
My career, I'm shortly going to
be the worst CEO of all time.
[COUGH] I was CEO for two months and
we liquidated the company.
What am I going to do?
And all this kind of me, me, me stuff.
[COUGH]
Which again,
I don't feel badly about that.
That's natural.
You get into jobs and
you kind of worry about your career and
I was still worried about my career and
what I was going to do.
And here I knew this company
was going to liquidate.
And here is the career story.
I go and
on that flight home from DC to Phoenix.
I always get up and talk to our team and
crew, because it's important and
I learn from them.
But I didn't want to go talk to the flight
crew, because this is front page news.
No one knew yet about this letter,
but everyone was asking so
I knew they were going to ask.
And I knew I couldn't lie
to the flight attendants.
So I was contemplating just spending
this four hours in my seat.
But then I thought I can't do that,
I gotta get up, so I go back and talk and
I'm glad I did.
This flight attendant in the back asked me
what's going on, I tell her, well, gee,
it doesn't look to good right now, I just
We're fighting through it but I just,
I don't feel good about it and she says,
well what's that going to mean?
I said, well look if we can't get this
done, you know, we'll file bankruptcy and
we'll try and hang on but
I don't feel good about that either and
she just looks at me and
says you can't do that.
I've been doing this job for ten years,
I'm a single mom, I've got my
life arranged around this flight
attendant job, I can't do anything else,
I'm really good at it, which, by the way,
she was, because I'd seen her.
And you just can't let that happen.
And I'm like, [LAUGH] So
okay, but no, it was really humble.
So I went back, sat in my seat,
pulled out the damn letter again,
and realized that it said at this time,
cannot prove it at this time.
So okay, I landed that night,
we went straight to work.
We worked all weekend.
We showed back up in DC Monday morning,
John with us.
With a new application.
And these guys in treasury said,
what are you doing here?
You said not this time.
Here's another application.
We're not going away.
And we kept fighting.
And we didn't give up.
>From that time, that airline, that little
Ameriquest airline had to have that loan.
That little airline American West Airlines
lived off of wage advantages.
Other airlines went through bankruptcy and
got their wages down to ours.
>> Mm-hm.
>> So all of the sudden we had a new
problem, which was we didn't have the
revenue generating capability they did,
but they had the same
cost structure as us now.
[INAUDIBLE]?
So we had to do a merger.
So we merged with US Airways.
And then US Airways ended up with
essentially the same kind of problems so
we ended up merging with American.
All those things,
none of those, from the time of
that encounter was I spending time
thinking what's best for my career.
Every one of them was, I'm responsible for
these hard working people.
Who, if we don't do our jobs right,
aren't going to have a job.
And it's not their fault.
These people are fantastic.
They're depending upon us to make sure
that we put the company in a position
where they don't have to
worry about whether or
not the company's going to be there for
them.
So the reason they work so
hard for those mergers,
and the reason I personally work so
hard on it was not because we wanted to
get ourselves in a position of being CEO
of the largest airline in the world,
is because that was the only way to
get that group of people safe harbor.
Anyway, and so the moral of the story is,
from the time I stopped thinking about my
career and
started thinking about doing my job for
a bigger cause, my career took off.
And so anyway, I like that part.
So my message of this is, it's hard to do.
[COUGH] You always hear people
say go do what you love.
To which I thought, that's BS.
I love playing basketball, but, [COUGH]
>> [LAUGH]
>> [COUGH]
Nobody's going to pay me to do that, but
I think what really is true,
if you can figure out a way to make what
you do be bigger than just you,
that'll work out really well for you.
And again, it's not that easy.
It's a lot like saying, do what you love.
But if you can find a way,
once you find that, don't let go of it,
because that's when things
really start happening.
When you're not just, because look, if it
had been me, if I had been worried, gee,
I want to be CEO of American Airlines,
at some point during this whole fight,
I would have said,
CEO of US Airways isn't that bad.
I'm fine.
I'm doing fine.
I don't have to move.
This was okay.
But that never crossed our minds,
because this was, no, no, no,
we gotta get this done for
all these people that are counting on us.
So.
And I'm glad you bring up the mergers
because I wanted to ask before
we talk about the success of the US
Airways American merger about what you
learned from the failed attempts to
merge with United and Continental.
>> They weren't failures.
>> Good, I'm already learning.
>> You're reading it upside-down again.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And, look, this is back to the risk
thing, and of course,
this is perceived as failure.
But I'm really glad we did it.
The first one that Gracie is referring to
was shortly after doing the America West,
US Airways merger, and
we were actually shorter than this part,
we were just one year into it.
Delta Airlines was in bankruptcy,
they were about to emerge from bankruptcy.
We came up with a great idea
bringing them out of bankruptcy with
a merger with the then-US Airways,
which hadn't even really merged
with America West very well yet.
But it was a good idea.
It would have been a really good airline.
And the Delta team didn't like it,
so it turned into a hostile.
[COUGH] Which doesn't happen very often,
hostiles of companies in bankruptcy.
But we tried it.
We knew going in it was high risk and
probably more likely than not not to work
but it was rolling the six on the die.
Huge upside [COUGH] if it worked,
excuse me.
And if it didn't work, it didn't work.
And also, if it didn't work,
what we knew is,
we were going to, they would have
to figure out something else to do.
And they did.
What happened is, long story short, that
group of people when you're in bankruptcy,
you don't have a board,
you have creditors.
Well, you have a board.
But the people running the company are the
people that you stiffed, so the people
they owe money that aren't getting paid
are now in control of the company.
And those people who you are appealing to
by saying, look, you'll get much more of
your money back if you do this with us
than with them, kind of believed us but
at the end said,
look we're going to stick with them.
But they insisted that,
that board be changed.
That board put people on
that were pro-consolidation,
including Richard Anderson,
who now runs the place.
And shortly after the merger,
that Northwest,
that Delta went and
did a merger with Northwest.
I don't think that would have
happened if we had done the hostile.
And if Delta hadn't merged with Northwest,
then our next aborted attempt that
we failed at was trying to then,
after that happened,
merge US Airways and United.
>> Yeah.
And we got pretty close there but
United eventually told us no and
picked Continental instead.
So United merged with Continental, another
thing that wouldn't have happened had we
not tried to get the first one done.
So anyway, I was being flippant
with you saying we didn't fail.
>From the outside those are failures.
And that's getting back to my point.
I don't feel badly about them at all.
And people would write at the time,
gee, again putting it all on me,
Doug failed at this merger attempt.
But it didn't do exactly what we wanted.
We wanted them both to work, but
it progressed us to where we
could do what we needed to do.
And it moved the industry
where it needed to move and
there was no one else out there
trying to make that happen.
I don't know where we'd be if
we hadn't tried do those things.
>> And so with American,
I think one of the reasons it was so
successful was you built this strong
relationship with the labor unions.
Can you talk about the freights and
what about you as a leader made
those relationships so successful?
>> Well again, not all me.
A really good team of
people who cared about so
much about taking care of our team that
we knew that we could do so much for
them that we also knew is going to be
best for the employees of American.
So, but we did the, rather non-traditional
step of while American was in bankruptcy,
beginning negotiations,
[LAUGH] so, we're at US Airways,
we started negotiating with
the American Airlines unions for
a contract that we would be willing
to sign, if indeed a merger got done.
These people didn't work for us,
[LAUGH] they worked for American.
And we're meeting with them in Phoenix and
signing contracts with them.
Which, look, I didn't do lightly.
I know it offended my friends in American
that we were meeting with their employees.
But again,
we had to get this done for our team.
It was the right thing to do.
So to your point, we recognize and
we learned it in the Delta
transaction frankly.
We did have the creditors on
board in the Delta transaction.
What we didn't get was
the employees on board.
They were very proud of Delta.
They wanted to stay with Delta and
that hurt us.
So we recognized we needed
to get the team on board.
So we approached American's employees.
We laid out for
them what we planned to do.
We told them why we thought it was better.
They agreed, and it wouldn't
have gotten done with out them..
It worked out well.
>> And now that the merger is successful,
your the CEO of the largest airline in
the world,
120,000 employees around the globe.
You're also the father of three.
>> Yes.
>> How does being a CEO
compare to being a father?
>> [LAUGH] Father's a lot harder.
I don't know.
I have great kids.
I try really hard to be
a father more than a CEO.
My job, I probably spend more
hours at CEO, unfortunately.
But frankly, I learned so
much from being a father
that I can use at work.
[COUGH]
Anyway,
raising children is this amazing thing.
Everybody does it at some point so
it's not like I'm an expert here.
But just watching the development and
watching how people interact and
watching how your kids interact
helps me a lot to understand and
to actually go manage the company.
So I learned a lot more about, I've
become a better CEO because I'm a father.
I try really hard to be
a good father as well.
I do things to make sure that
I'm home as much as I can be.
This is a rarity for
me where I'm out of town for
a night, and it's not required work,
but I wanted do it.
>> Appreciate it.
>> Well, I wanted to do it for George.
And I appreciate it as well.
So I try and stay home as much as I can.
My job requires me to travel.
I refuse to do,
I almost never do work dinners in Dallas.
If I'm going to be home,
I'm going to have a meal with my kids.
If somebody wants to meet with me, of
course, that's important to the company.
We can do it at lunch or breakfast,
or we can do it at my office.
But there's no reason for
me to be going to a dinner in Dallas.
So I have rules like that.
That I just make sure that I stay engaged,
stay balanced.
>> When you moved to Dallas after
the acquisition was that a family
conversation about how you balance
where the kids have been raised
versus where you're doing work?
>> Yes.
>> [LAUGH]
>> You're good at this.
>> So do you want to hear this story?
>> I do.
>> Okay, sorry.
You know, it's horrible.
I said the worst day of my life was
that day that I got the letter.
This might have been the worst day of my,
this was a really hard day.
My kids, my eldest who's 20,
was born in Minneapolis,
when I was at Northwest, but
we moved when he was three weeks old.
And the other two were born in Phoenix,
and that's where they were raised.
>> And this merger was in
the papers all the time.
One day my daughter,
who at the time I guess was,
she's 15 now, so she was 13,
sends me a text and
says Mrs. Roswell told me
the mergers going through [LAUGH].
>> Who's Mrs. Roswell?
>> Mrs. Roswell's a friend of a friend.
Like, well,
I don't know before Mrs. Roswell.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And I promise I'll tell you.
But because things would happen like
a rumor that we got a deal done
with the unions.
And okay, the merge has gone
through is the way gets reported.
So all of a sudden my kids
are just going crazy.
So anyway they didn't want to move.
So anyway, the bad part was
when we finally did do it, and
I'd been telling them all along,
quit listening to everybody else.
When I tell you is when it's happening.
Don't worry about it until then.
So they at least had some comfort in that.
And then one day I had to come home and
Clara would say hey,
I need to talk to you.
And as soon as my daughter walked, I said
hey, I need to talk to you and pulled her.
And we'd already had the two boys and
my wife there.
And she walked in the room and
just saw that they were there and
just started sobbing.
So, aren't you glad you
made me to tell that story?
>> I'm sorry.
>> It's all right.
So no, it was really real, but
look, that's stuff you gotta do.
She's fantastic.
She's fine now.
She wouldn't leave Dallas.
So it's all fine.
But, yeah,
that was the bad part of doing this.
And again, it gets back to, look,
if we were just doing this for ourselves,
we would have stayed where we were.
We were perfectly fine and happy.
But you gotta do what's right for
the organization.
>> And now that you're at this point,
the merger, the final pieces have come
together, hopefully friends have
been made in Dallas, what's next for
American as a company, and
what's next for you as CEO?
>> Well, look,
we have set an objective for
ourselves of becoming the greatest airline
in the world, and we're not there yet.
So we have a lot of work to do.
We spent the last two years integrating,
which sounds boring and it is.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But it's really hard work.
And it takes a lot of time and
effort, and our team has just
knocked the ball out of the park.
But now we've gotten through
the vast majority of that.
We still have some left.
And now we really need go start producing
now that we are working as one airline.
And we know what we need to do.
Our objective is to be
the best in the world and
that's a somewhat nebulous term,
but we know we're not it now.
So that at least we know we
have to make some progress, but
what it certainly means is you gotta
be an airline that people want to fly.
You have to be an airline
where people want to work, and
you have to be an airline where
investors want to put their money.
And we're doing okay on each of those,
but we can do a lot better on each.
And we're not the best at any of them, and
we want to be the best at all of them.
So we're going to make huge
improvements to the product.
It's already begun.
That includes the operational
liability issues that you mentioned.
But it also includes entire modernization
of the fleet, brand new airplanes.
We now have the youngest fleet in
the world, or in the United States.
We have, that includes WiFi
throughout all our airplanes,
including international,
lie-flat seats international.
Taking our air miles clubs to look like
the kind of clubs you'd see when you
fly internationally, not just when
you fly in the United States.
So making it a true global airline
with a real global product.
So we have a lot of work to do, and
we have a lot of work to do with our team.
There's a lot of history at American
Airlines of management-labor relations
that are just horrible.
I'm not trying to say anything
bad about prior management.
They had a really difficult
situation to go through.
But the result was a really,
really bad history that's hard for
people to let go of.
And so we're trying to convince people
that that's over and this is new.
And we try and
figure out ways to do that everyday,
just surprise people with something
to say wow, that's different.
This feels different.
So we gotta lot of work
to do with out team, too.
And by the way, it's incredibly
important to the first one.
That the airline business is so
much about the employees that you
interact with and their attitudes.
So if we can get our employees to be
excited about being where they are,
our customers will be much
happier on the airplane.
And that'll help us drive more
passengers to the airline.
And that'll help us meet our goals of
getting a return for our investors.
So it starts with the employees.
>> A lot of exciting work ahead.
>> Thanks.
>> Excellent, I'd like to open up
to the audience now for questions.
I think our first one is from Twitter.
>> Yeah, that's right.
Thanks both for a wonderful conversation.
So the first question from Twitter comes
from a chap called Jake who says that
the Economist wrote that airlines
are wonderful generators of profit for
everyone except in sales.
How do you envision changing that,
especially with headwinds such
as climate change and so forth?
>> Yeah, that was true from
the beginning of time until recently.
Look, this airline,
this business, is transformed.
And I believe that as much as I can
believe it, as much as I can possibly
stress, no one not no one,
very few others seem to believe it.
The market doesn't believe it, as you
can see with the way our stocks trading
versus what we're looking
at in terms of earnings.
It's hard for our employees to believe it.
It's hard for
the management team to believe it.
But this is, and it's obviously hard for
the economists to believe it but
look, this is a real business now.
We're producing real returns and
we've got a business now that
it's still a cyclical business.
People will fly less in bad times and
fly more in good times.
But we're producing profits
now that are in line with
the general industry,
actually a little ahead of them.
Peaks, double the highest earnings
in the industry that are produced.
Hopefully, we're not at
peak margins right now.
So I think the industry has been
largely transformed mostly due
to the consolidation that we discussed so
that's what we needed to do.
The problem with the world before where
everyone else made money and we didn't.
All of our suppliers made money,
Boeing made money.
That's probably how America West and
others stayed around because
those who lived off our carcass needed
us to be around a little more so
they loaned us money to
keep us kicking around.
On three occasions,
I've received loans from either GE or
Airbus, to save a company
from going bankruptcy.
We're going into bankruptcy,
America West and US Airways.
But no one talks about that anymore.
We're not even kind of doing that.
We raised last week a billion dollars
of aircraft financing at below 4%.
So anyway, the answer to that question if
you asked me five years ago or ten years
ago was we got to get consolidation done
because the industry is too fragmented.
And we can't provide to
consumers what they want,
which is the ability to have one airline
take them everywhere they want to go.
And as a result we all end up trying to do
that, and we're incredibly inefficient.
So anyway, I think we're past it.
A lot of questions.
>> There's mics going around.
Thank you.
>> Morning, thanks for coming.
>> Sure.
>> Really appreciated your remarks
on teamwork.
It made me think right away of
one of your agents in Raleigh,
her name is Tammy Fields.
We fly a ton.
And she has basically adopted our family.
She keeps an eye on like award seat
searches that we're trying to do to Tokyo
or somewhere and
calls me up when something comes through.
Just so far above and
beyond the call of duty.
We were stranded one time in Peru.
It was Tammy that got us out of
the fix and got us flights and
pulled whatever strings
needed to be pulled.
Really the kind of success
story you're looking for.
I'd like to give you her name when
you're finished if that's okay.
>> I've got it, and I see my colleague
down there typing it into his iPhone.
We got Tammy Fields in Raleigh.
>> Tammy Fields in Raleigh.
>> We will definitely let her know.
>> Thank you for telling me.
We do, we have a phenomenal
group of people like those.
Thanks for telling me.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Hi,
I wanted to ask about how you keep
loyal customers given the recent
award program devaluation among
your competitors United and Delta.
And American Americans impending
award devaluation of March 22nd.
How do you look at customer loyalty and
maintain their trust and their business?
>> Yeah, thanks.
We don't view it as devaluation,
we view it as a change.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And look it is, these programs
when they were established for
whatever reason, they were established as
we measured loyalty by
how many miles you fly.
And that's one way to do it, but we
don't report our PNL as miles flown minus
expenses, it's revenues minus expenses.
And what's more important and
what we want to reward for
most people miles on revenues
are a reasonable approximation,
but with that model you have these
very very odd things we created.
People finding the lowest
possible fare they could find.
And spending their weekends flying around
the lowest fares they could find so
that they could get free
travel somewhere else.
Look, we love those people,
those are customers of ours.
But when that happens what we as
an airline are choosing to do is
give that individual a first
class seat to Paris instead of
the individual who didn't
fly as many miles.
And actually spent his time and
weekends at home, but
during the week paid full fair and
that's not the right model.
So it's a shift in the model.
It's one of these things again
where it's a transformation.
So everyone that grew up in that old model
says that you're making this worse for
me, but we're not making it worse for
everyone.
It's worse for some, it's better for
others and I think it's more fair and
more equitable.
And it's rewarding what we want to reward,
which is those people who fly us,
who pay the most.
And who purchase the fares that
are not just going around and trying
to find $100 fares Transcon on a weekend
to figure out how you get more miles.
So again, it's great they do that.
We encourage that by the model we had.
We like to actually have those seats for
the people that are producing
the most revenue for us.
>> Hello, Tobias from Germany.
I would like to talk about technology
because I haven't heard this at all today.
I remember like 15 years ago I was
reading somewhere Internet in airplanes.
I got very excited.
I was very addictive to
Internet back then and
then it took 15 years until at least in
Europe it was most of the airplanes a and
even now EasyJet right now,
Lufthansa just started.
It took like 15 years until
people were able to use Internet.
In US, it was a bit earlier but
it was still taking a long time.
So my question is like how in the future
you can guarantee that technology is being
integrated much earlier into airplanes,
especially in regards
of customer experience.
Because I would love to have all
within American Airlines app I
could upgrade myself during a plane,
maybe for a special price,
business class where maybe could skip the
line or maybe get fast boarding because
there's no large queue and
I feel like I'm just tired.
I really feel like
the customer experience,
which a lot of online
companies are offering and
the mobile technologies out there
has arrived at the airlines?
>> Thank you very much.
Look, we're moving as fast
as we possibly can and
because of customer demand, because of
people like you, who are insisting.
The reality is Wi-Fi on aircraft
now that you talked about
there I remember Russ sitting around and
debating it and jeez, there's
no way you can possibly pay for yourself,
you gotta carry this stuff around.
These are antennas that communicate
down the cell towers and
they're really expensive and
they're heavy and people got it moved.
There's no way we're going to,
people pay for it.
But once it was on the airplane, on a few,
customers started saying,
this airplane doesn't have Wi-Fi anymore?
So there's no choice,
because we needed to have Internet.
It came really quickly, so
I don't know if that was so
much technology as maybe
resistance from airlines to
go do something that we
couldn't cause just as one.
But that's all behind us now and
this is going so fast,
we're all trying to figure how
it lead from somebody else.
As it relates to some of the things
you're talk about we're working
diligently to figure out everything
we can to make sure the customer
experience can be done as much
through technology as possible.
Some of the things you describe we just
simply can't do because the regulations we
have to live with.
I can tell you right now,
if the way I travel and
the way probably most of you travel,
there's no reason for
me to see an individual
until I get on the airplane.
There's no reason to
have an interaction or
even to see an American Airlines
employee until I get,
because I'm not checking a bag and
I've got my boarding pass, my iPhone,
and I hand it to someone, who then puts
it under the thing, and I can do that.
But we're not allowed to not
have an agent stand there, and
just let an individual decide that
they're going to get on the airplane.
So some of this is just requirements
that we're always going to have, but
we can do a lot better and
we're working really hard at it.
I can tell you American Airlines
as it relates to this,
we're putting Internet onto
our international flights.
It's not on all of them yet, but
we're way ahead of the game there.
So trans Atlantic,
things you couldn't do before.
Now we're shooting up satellites
instead of going down to cell towers.
And with that technology that's new
technology, now we can actually provide
Wi-Fi service anywhere in the air, so
we're moving to that as quickly as we can.
So we'll keep working on it but
we agree with you.
>> I'm afraid I'm going to take the last
question for myself, which thanks.
Which is-
>> You earned it.
>> [LAUGH] Thank you, I've tried.
>> Yeah.
>> What advice do you have for
the MBAs in the room?
If you could go back and
it's your time at Owen.
What do you wish you could tell yourself?
>> Again, so many of your would go off and
live in your basements.
So I'm not sure what to tell you about.
>> [LAUGH]
>> About how to do that.
You're smarter than I am.
But what I can tell you is what I do
know at least from a more traditional
perspective, where you
go show up at a job.
I was honored that's part of
the introduction to have this
the relationships matter piece mentioned.
That's what I think, what I believe is and
what I would encourage,
the reason I was talking
to everybody like this, and
what I told them was what I
have learned in my career.
I know it's taught at business schools and
it seems so
matter of fact that why do you even teach
it, but you can't stress it enough.
It's how important relationships are and
how you treat people in
your relative success.
And there's this perception amongst some
outside of business that business is this,
the way you get ahead is backstabbing,
cutthroat that doesn't work at all.
It worked for a short period of time but
you'll be done and you'll go need to find
another job before too long in another
industry because it doesn't work.
What matters is people that in
every relationship they have,
you treat people with respect and dignity
and you show up and do your job well.
I watch people and I don't think they
fully appreciate is, from the time you
walk in the door that starts, and
you're building relationships with people.
And you don't have any idea,
you can't possibly decide
that's the person somebody really need to
have a relationship and that person's not.
That's what I've learned through
all this crazy story of all
the stuff I've been through.
This American Airlines, US Airways merger,
we ended up with people in part of
this process that helped us out.
That 15 years ago, we worked on
this project and at that time,
there's no way we would have thought that
individual was going to be representing
the flight attendants who are really
important to us at that time.
But thank goodness we treated
that person well, 15 years ago.
And if they hadn't been treated maybe so
well from the other side,
it made a huge difference.
So anyway, the message is this.
You're going to,
from the day you walk in the door you're
going to start these relationships.
And if you try and say I care
about that person not that person,
that's not going to work.
So treat everybody the same.
Treat everybody, and if you do that
the people that do that versus those
who don't, do it dramatically better.
And I think that's
the biggest key as anything.
So you give somebody the same intellect,
energy, integrity, all that, but
not the ability to build relationships
with somebody who can, and
they're going to have
dramatically different careers.
So that would be my advice,
just be nice to people.
>> That's great advice-
>> Thanks.
>> Thank you so much Doug.
It's been amazing.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]